so so let's change the let's change the
analogy first of all just as an aside
right we overuse
business uh we overuse sports or war
analogies in business right those things
are about winning
those things are very finite driven and
so we need to sort of change the mindset
that this is not a game like baseball or
football
this is not a battle to be won but it's
more like a lifestyle think of it more
like being healthy that to be healthy
there's a number of things that we have
to do we all know what they are you have
to eat eat well you have to exercise you
have to get enough sleep you have to
nurse your personal relationships some
would argue there's 20 or 30 other
things it's very difficult to do all of
those things well all of the time they
sort of go like this you know we let one
go while we're doing well with another
and it's a striving we all know this
um and think of business the same way
there's so many things that we have to
do to lead a successful business right
we have to do our marketing we have to
do our sales we have to do a
relationship building we have to be
structured we have to have we have to
have systems all of these things very
hard to do all of them all the time it's
a striving much easier to do when we ask
for help as we've talked about before
just like you have a gym buddy you can
have a leadership buddy um
uh and so the the same goes for the
infinite game which is there are
multiple multiple practices
um to uh embody an infinite mindset you
need to have that sense of just cause
you need to know that the skills of
building trusting teams you need to
study your worthy rivals you need to
uh
have a capacity for existential
flexibility and you need to have the
courage to lead
you have to do all of them at some point
it doesn't matter where you start you're
gonna have to do all of them at some
point the easiest one to embody and to
embrace is studying your worthy rivals
um so
in a finite game we have competitors
right and that competitor is there to be
beaten
we have to stop talking about the other
players in our game as competitors
because they're not we're not actually
competing against them we're competing
alongside of them very very different so
change the terminology to rivals there
are other players the other people who
do what i do or my rivals and some of
those rivals are worthy of comparison
which means some of them do one or many
things better than i do which means that
their strengths reveal to me my
weaknesses and instead of trying to beat
them
rather i can respect them i don't have
to like them or agree with them
but i can now have my weaknesses
revealed and i can now work on those
weaknesses i can work to build on those
weaknesses the reason is simple because
i need to stay in the game as long as
possible i don't care how long they stay
in the game whether they survive a day
or a year or 10 years or forever is not
it has nothing to do with me the goal is
that my business survives for as long as
i want it to whether it's my lifetime or
beyond my lifetime
um
and so those decisions are going to be
very very different so stop thinking of
the other players as competitors start
respecting the ones who are better than
you
and like as i said before their
strengths reveal to your weaknesses
maybe they have better leadership maybe
they have better marketing maybe they
have better relationship building maybe
they have better returns
study them understand what they're doing
learn from them to make yourself a
better player that's the easiest one you
can do and you can start that tomorrow